thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
welcome for you all I see a couple of
new faces but for those that don't know
me and those that do know me I'm Miriam
great to have you all here as I say
every week that I'm up here and mean it
every single week so a couple quick
announcements for you before we get
started
um
first off it is the first Sunday of the
month so we all know that we have our
dinner at hat Creek for those that
haven't been here before or aren't
familiar with that what we do is after
the service every Sunday the first
Sunday of the month we meet over at hat
Creek I usually just type it in my GPS
but this is in sexy off of Woodbridge
and Highway 75.
wouldn't know where that was if you told
me but just tell you 78 78. see I'm not
I don't live over here I live off of 75
so my bad Woodbridge is 78
um hat Creek so right after the service
we just Fellowship have a meal there
hang out as long or as little as you
want we'd love to have you and everyone
is welcome
the second announcement is we are having
a welcome to the table class so again if
you're interested in becoming a member
of the table or you just want to learn
more about us as a church or in a
community we'd love to have you it's on
Sunday August 27th it'll be here in the
church from 3 to 4 30 p.m in the room
right next to the kitchen so that room
right there
um sign up with a little card if you go
out the store there's a little table
there's some White cards out there and
just uh put your name your information
and then just put wtt class welcome to
the table class and then we will contact
you and coordinate that so without
further Ado I believe I'm handing off to
Brittany yes for our summer team
thank you
okay you may notice we have some very um
festive decorations up here
500 remember
that's what TR said
um so we this weekend we had summer Rama
which is basically like our VBS we do it
two days instead of throughout the week
and our theme this year was Making Waves
which I really loved because I think
sometimes kids can feel like they you
know like they have no impact in the
world they're kids right but so we
learned this week that what did we learn
small
actions
big impact yes so
um they wanted to teach you guys one of
the songs that we learned this weekend
and the dance that goes with it
um so in a second I'm going to call them
up but before I do that I wanted to
thank all of our volunteers
um
as much as I love this
I know it's more of a sacrifice for some
adults to take their entire weekend to
spend with kids so
um thank you for that and we have some
special guests that are going to come up
here and help us learn this dance TR
and Chad and Austin Larry Larry Bob was
not feeling good tonight so he's not
coming but they're gonna come up and the
kids you guys can come up
come on y'all come on
Larry Bob doesn't feel good he's not
here
[Music]
you make me move Jesus said
I take that faith in you
every step I take I've taken you you are
my way Jesus every time
[Music]
yeah every step I take I think
everything
[Music]
everywhere
[Applause]
[Music]
her days
[Applause]
[Music]
God
you guys thank you so much all right
please follow your kids ministry leaders
back to your classrooms I see Miss
Maggie waving back there
thank you Julie Kelly Brittany Elena
everyone who's serving in kids tonight
thank you guys so much and again for our
volunteers who led summer Rama that was
an incredible feat you guys I wish I
could have been here to see the
decorations and all the pictures and the
crafts and it was just like such an
offering of love from these
um from these teachers and teen helpers
and uh just and a reminder to me like
that the kingdom of God is holistic you
know it's not just what we do here on
Sunday nights in this room with the
adults like it's all of us from the top
to the bottom it's every human it's
every age it's
um just such a beautiful picture so
um I hope that that touched Joel's heart
because it definitely touched mine
we're gonna go ahead and start off with
or not start off continue with a few
other songs if y'all want to stand with
us
our set is a little bit shorter tonight
just because we wanted to leave plenty
of time for the kids to share with us
I'm gonna jump right into it so you guys
uh bring your hearts heart first is how
I want us to engage worship it's more
than the music it's really about what's
going on in here so I hope you feel at
home and the room and the space to
engage what's what's going on on the
inside
foreign
[Music]
but you
leave
the truth
[Applause]
I believe
[Music]
through every promise
to every breath I take
and I believe that you are provided
you are protected
you are the one I love
[Music]
the truth
I believe
[Music]
the truth
[Applause]
I believe
thank you
it's a New Horizon
and I'll set on you and you meet me here
today with mercies that are new all my
fears and doubts
they can all come too because they can't
stay long when I'm here with you
[Music]
New Horizon
when I'm set on you
you meet me here today
all my fears and doubts
they can all come true
[Music]
the shoes
you meet me here today
[Music]
[Applause]
true
the light
I believe you are
[Music]
going to move into the prayers of the
people so if you have something that
you're carrying on your heart tonight
a person or a situation we invite you as
we go through this prayer together to
offer it up and hold it in the space and
we would like to hold that with you
before God
would you guys read this aloud with me
for this city of Sachse Texas and for
every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you
for The Good Earth you have given us and
the wisdom and the will to conserve it
we pray to you
for the old and the sick for the Widow
and orphan for the injured and suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them we pray to you
for the vulnerable the marginalized and
those unjustly targeted for their gender
sexuality and race or other perceived
difference we pray to you for those
experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you
Lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us and so we lift these names
and situations up to you
[Music]
Stephanie and Ryan
rickleyman
[Music]
for the names and the moments that we've
spoken aloud and for those that we have
kept in our hearts we pray to you that
they may have life and light healing and
hope peace and a deep sense of your
presence
amen
[Music]
I love you Lord
oh your mercy never fails me
Oh my days I've been held in your hands
from the moment I wake up
until I lay my head I will sing of the
goodness of God
[Music]
I love your voice
you have led me through the fire
dark is nice you are close like no other
I've known you as a father
I've known you as a
friend
[Music]
sing all my life you've been faithful
for all my life you have been faithful
[Music]
all my life you have been so so good
I will see of the goodness of God
sing I love your voice I love your voice
you have led me through the fire
the dark is nice
[Music]
I've known you as a father
I've known you as event
I have lived in the goodness of God
oh my life you have been faithful
all my life you have been so so
good
with every breath
I will see
all the goodness of God sing your
goodness your goodness is
[Music]
your goodness
touching me
I told my life you have been faithful
all my life you have been so
so good
with every breath
I will sing of the goodness of God
[Music]
Jesus we're so grateful
for a God who came and experienced this
life as a man
experience the struggles and the pain
the Heartbreak
thank you
God I believe that you are close to the
Brokenhearted
[Music]
I believe that you see us when we're in
our valleys when are at our lowest
points you're there beside us you are
walking through the pits with us
and because you're that kind of God we
can sing these words in truth and say
all our lives you are faithful
all the time you are good
not because our situations are always
perfect
not because we are without our pains
our addictions our struggles our
Brokenness
but because you have stayed beside us
because you have been a friend
to the Brokenhearted a defender of the
weak
you have been beside the Widow and the
orphan
you know our struggles
and we trust you in that God we trust
you to be faithful with whatever we're
facing today we trust that you are
enough that you will see us through that
you will keep pulling us forward into
the way of Jesus into the path of love
and healing and Hope
[Music]
God we invite you into this life
into this broken weary beautiful
mysterious life
we pray that we could find you right in
the midst of it with us
Jesus name
[Music]
thank you guys would you all turn to the
people around us I know several people
are new tonight can you make them feel
welcome and at home and then we will
kick off our message
thank you
you're done
well good evening grace and peace
super good to be with you all and um I
want to extend a warm welcome to all of
you and that includes those joining us
online uh as well as those of you who
are new thanks for being Among Us
um my name is Brett I'm the pastor here
though if you visited for the first time
in the last four weeks you wouldn't know
that I've been like the absentee pastor
and I was on my my every July I try to
take some some time off and so
um very grateful for a church family
that lets me do such things and it was
just incredibly well I mean as you can
imagine it was restful it was great I
yeah many books were read
many walks were taken at least in the uh
early morning or later at night because
yep it was Blazing as it continues to be
um but it really was it was just yeah it
was a great great time so um but I'm
glad to be back very very glad and after
like two and a half three weeks I'm kind
of like okay it's good I'm good
it's time so
um yes I'm really grateful I also wanted
to um a few things one I want to thank
everyone like Elder team Ministry team
leaders we had some wonderful folks who
spoke like the first week it was
um Miriam doing the the panel discussion
with Carrie and Gary and and then after
that
um what was the order was it Laurie
proven first and then Jesse and then
last week Megan and Christian lots of
people speaking and uh just filling in
so so so grateful
um for you all yeah so um
we are let's see we're kicking off a new
series tonight
and uh it's gonna be on the Book of
James we each year I always like to do
like at least one you know book of the
Bible
um last year we did the book of First
Peter and I totally burnt everyone out
on it like we did like I don't know how
maybe not I don't know I'm not gonna ask
for a show of hands as to who was burnt
out
um
I remember like because we did like a
whole series like I don't know seven or
eight weeks on it took a break did some
other stuff and then we came back to it
and I thought at least a few faces that
were kind of like oh more first Peter
huh
um but uh so I'm gonna kind of limit it
a little bit we'll do just like I don't
know six seven weeks on the Book of
James we won't go like you know line by
line verse by verse through it um we'll
just hit on like some of the major uh
themes from the from the book so
um
the uh kind of some I want to give a
little background on it before you know
since we're going to spend so many weeks
it'd be nice to know like all right so
um what's this book of James about and
uh so it was written by
James
um yeah they're tracking and uh so
specifically though I mean there was
this was a very very common name in the
like um first century uh so this church
history has it that this was written by
um James the brother of Jesus
uh which I think that's something like
we we know from the gospels that the
family was a little bit not so much
Merry but the rest of the family was a
little skeptical about everything going
on with Jesus
um and so I think it's quite telling
that his own brother came to be one of
the primary leaders of the church in
Jerusalem uh that saying I mean right
because we can I don't know I'm just
imagining like some Guru or cult like
figure you know I mean they like
bamboozle I don't know like strangers
you know what I mean but their own
family is like whatever I grew up with
you I know who you are you know so it's
I mean it's quite um insightful that
James himself
um at least post Resurrection believed
and uh so he I was a leader of the
church in Jerusalem
um in terms of when the book was written
uh probably sometime well we know
there's a Jewish historian named
Josephus who
um tells us that James the brother of
Jesus died in 6280s that's like 30 years
or so after Jesus like his resurrection
Ascension so sometime in that window
maybe 40 50 you know 80 maybe 10 20
years um so it's one of the earliest
books in the New Testament
um and uh then finally the audience
because James is like overseeing the
Church of Jerusalem the audience is
primarily kind of Jewish Believers
um there and around Jerusalem so
the uh the message specific to tonight
um is a little bit of a strange title
you all know if you've been here before
you know I'm fond of strange titles
either one word titles or strange titles
um so it's Faith epidurals and midwives
and uh hopefully it will make sense by
the end
um our passage is from the very opening
of James chapter one verses one through
four which reads uh James
a servant of God and of the Lord Jesus
Christ
to the 12 tribes scattered among the
Nations
consider it pure joy my brothers and
sisters whenever you face Trials of many
kinds because you know that the testing
of your faith produces perseverance
let perseverance finish its work so that
you may be mature and complete not
lacking anything
so I'm I'm kind of intrigued by how that
hits you it's
um verse 2 there consider it pure joy my
brothers and sisters whenever you face
Trials of many kinds uh I just I don't
know I'm kind of curious like how does
it you know I don't know maybe does do
you find it kind of
um encouraging like sort of uplifting
this idea that even in the midst of my
suffering
um I could I could find some Joy I could
find some you know encouragement in it
okay like that could be sort of one
reaction
um I know do you
does it kind of discourage you like
um I mean at any given time
at some level we're all suffering like
to be human is to often right kind of
suffer and sort of more minor ways and
then kind of obviously it's scales
scales up from there uh so I wonder if
you could also maybe find it kind of
discouraging like oh good yet another
way I'm failing God
like I'm supposed to be counted pure joy
you know I can't do that
um
so maybe for some it's like discouraging
maybe others find it
um a little bit kind of infuriating
because it's like it may just strike you
as yet another example of
um kind of a Christian version of toxic
positivity
this often runs quite rampant in the
church it's like in church circles often
we can't be sad for more than 2.5
seconds
without someone bringing up like well
remember consider it pure joy Brothers
like didn't you hear this there man you
know
um like Just Praise the Lord you know uh
yeah like maybe it it hits you in that
way I think of all the reactions I want
to speak to that last one it feels
the most kind of timely
um
yeah this is a tough one like okay so
what is this like toxic positivity so
this is not like an actual clinical term
um it's it but it's probably what
therapists they would um call avoidance
um so
like in essence let me give you kind of
a few examples of this so like let's say
um you are up for like promotion job
promotion
and you're pumped about it you know like
you've been there a while you deserve it
like all the things
and inexplicably
you don't get the position
immediately you know that moment like
when you get the news and you just feel
like all the emotions in your body in
your very being I mean it's like it's
crazy to be human isn't it I mean it's
just like a roller coaster in here and
so you just it hits you and it's like oh
my gosh feeling all of like some rage
you know just all this and you can tell
like you're distraught you need some
support you reach out to a friend
and just explain the whole situation you
know and their response is well
you know praise the Lord that you have a
job
now that's
toxic positivity Christian version
um
or maybe there's that maybe let's say
you're like going through a deep
depression
and so yet again like you can tell like
oh my gosh I need some support I need
some love
reach out to a friend kick him a text
explain it like I am just I'm in the
depths I'm in the darkness like it's
just everything is Bleak I'm struggling
um
this is the worst and
um they write back to you like well you
know you sound really negative right now
and
um
I think if you would just do away with
that you know that stinking thinking if
you would turn that frown upside down my
friend
um I bet by tomorrow morning
you'll feel better
you know
um
yeah that's that's toxic positive so
here's the weird thing about it is um
toxic positivity actually has nothing to
do with positivity or Joy or happiness
at all
which is sort of the irony of it
um and here's what I mean um going back
to that word it's about avoidance in
other words see when you bring things up
uh remember how you were a swirl of
emotions you were feeling it
well what happens to them not as strong
right but it stirs things up in them
and so I think I wrote down
like an honest text if they could have
been honest with you
um here's what they would have said look
my friend I'm still deeply anxious about
my own unresolved grief and suffering
such that when you sent me that text it
triggered my own challenging feelings
and honestly I cannot handle those right
now and so I'm going to offer you the
same solution that I have taken
Christian avoidance I'm going to pretend
that my challenging feelings don't exist
by offering you a Plucky Bible verse and
moving on with my life I suggest you
receive it and do the same
that would have been the honest text
right it's that's the the thing with
toxic positivity it's right not that
it's bad I mean as we'll get into that
is bad to name Joy or name like or that
there's such a thing as just doing a
doom Loop of spiraling negativity and
that's always something like no no right
so there's there's some truth in this
but you can see where
in the end it's actually
um
well as one of my professors used to say
we're always just bumping into ourselves
you know and that's that's what's
happening in that moment so I guess the
big question for our purposes tonight is
like is James chapter 1 verses one
through four and specifically verse two
is it just that
like does James just have people in his
church suffering and he's just like kind
of an insensitive jerk you know and it's
just like hey consider it pure joy you
know
there shall be no tears in my
congregation you know
um
well I think the tricky thing is
like clearly
this passage has been used in those ways
I mean if I had to list like top five
verses to be deployed in that way oh
James 1 verse two would be like the one
you know
um
and
so I think this what we kind of need to
do is um I think approach it in a little
bit deeper way because although it can
be deployed and used in that way I don't
think it has to be and I actually think
it will reflect on it there's I think
quite a deep
um word to us in the midst of our
suffering here that doesn't have to be a
weird kind of toxic positivity type spin
um and we just might find that actually
we can feel all sorts of feelings in the
midst of pain and sorrow and grief as
the wonderful American poet Walt Whitman
said
um it's because I am large I contain
multitudes
that Whitman is awesome
um now how how do we interpret this
passage in that way though I think much
of it hinges on those two words in verse
two pure joy
here I mean those are that's strong you
know like consider it pure joy um a new
testament scholar named Douglas moo
who's much more has a great last name
um he uh
says and he's way more versed in the
Greek than I am
um so I I think pastors can often do
more danger by going to the original
languages though I tend to just rely on
the scholars you know and um something
he points out is that this language in
the original
um Greek is really he thinks it's more
emphasizing the notion of intensity
as opposed to exclusivity
in other words when we hear pure joy or
as other translations say count it all
joy
oh you know what is that ring in your
ear it sounds like only exclusively ever
joy and happiness right you're suffering
right now turn that frown upside down
right that's kind of what it it sounds
like instead of the notion of intensity
which is um even in my suffering even in
my pain even in my grief which are very
real feelings and I'm deeply feeling
those right now at the same time Miracle
of Miracles I'm large and I contain
multitudes and suddenly I can find Joy
bubbling up again
the way I um might just kind of capture
in a sentence or or two is the trials of
life can be the occasions of the most
all of it intense grief
and what the most intense Joy the
deepest suffering and the deepest
meaning the most profound tears and the
widest smiles
I I think uh probably I guess as a
pastor I've been at many a funeral and
so what came to mind when I was kind of
reflecting all this was um
funerals
like I can always tell when a when a
community that gathers for a funeral is
sort of emotionally disengaged
from the person who passed away because
they just have no emotion like
whatsoever
now the thing is what you would think
though is if the person was like deeply
loved
and they love deeply in return
what you think is it would be pure grief
and suffering and loss in pain just the
most depressing difficult just the worst
the worst of funerals but actually no I
mean I'm sure almost all of you probably
have been to a funeral what happens
it's everything I just described
it is like gut-wrenching tears
and
laughing through those same tears 60
seconds later
I mean it's just it is this cathartic
kind of jumbled mixture of oh my gosh
how can all of these feelings and
emotions fit in this body like how and
but that's what it is it's like the
stories
stories become so I mean is this not so
true of our suffering especially when we
get through it I mean often we're in it
it's just sort of like okay now this
just um really sucks you know
um but when we get through it I mean do
we not often look back on those moments
and say like the most powerful moment in
my life like a turning point in my life
um what's going on there it is
emotionally Rich it is deep it is
powerful and somehow there's just
there's room for it all and so when
James says you know count it all joy as
some translation say or pure joy I don't
think he means again there shall be no
grief or sadness that any of Maya
Christian churches you know
um I don't think that's what he's saying
I think instead the idea is that as
Christians the trials of Life are not
dead ends but opportunities too a as
we've been kind of unpacking feel deeply
and be
um
mature spiritually as we take up our
cross and embrace our suffering and of
course that's right where James goes
um in verse three because you know he
says that the testing of your faith
produces perseverance let perseverance
finish its work so that you may be
mature and complete not lacking anything
I think what James is contending here is
that spiritual maturity it's never found
um by going
around our suffering
never
but always doing what
going straight through it
I mean every single time in fact we have
to be careful because again as we've
been talking about Bible verses can be
used to do what
like just we now of course really in the
end there's actually no getting around
it is there it's sort of like grief you
know I mean like when you need to grieve
you need to grieve but of course we can
kind of you know I'm just gonna avoid
that but it starts coming out sideways
and you know like sometimes actually
there's no getting around but you know
what I mean we do our best I mean I do
my best too often avoid
and yet always
I think following Jesus means
taking a deep breath
and going right through it
and I'm so proud of many of you I right
now you are going right
through it
right through it
and that is the most courageous thing
anyone can do that's true
faith
that's true faith not offering up Plucky
Bible verses so that I avoid it
right because there's um because there's
a way right that can kind of you can use
it cheaply hey consider pure joy you
know turn that promise in it right or
you can do it in a powerful
transformative
even in the midst of my suffering God
I'm here for it I'm here for As we sing
and I will live in the goodness of God
right in the midst of my hell
I will I will stand in it and walk
through it and find myself transformed
mature and complete
not lacking anything
um there's a quote this is from it says
Rachel held Evans in her book searching
for Sunday but she's actually quoting
brene Brown and a shout out to my wife
Maggie who uh pointed out to me we often
read you know at night and uh well like
hey
do you do you have time for a quote are
you okay am I throwing off your groove
if you have a you know I mean anyone is
like just I got a quote and she had this
he was like listen this quote I'd
already written this message and I was
like oh my gosh that is going in here
and it's gonna become the title which is
why the title makes sense
um
uh so this is brene brown
um says this I went to church thinking
it would be like an epidural
it would take the pain away
but Church isn't like an epidural
it's like a midwife
I thought Faith would say come here I'll
take away the pain and the discomfort
but what it ended up saying was
I'll sit with you in it
fit with you in it
I'll be with you in it here come on
let's do it together
let's do it together and I think this is
one of the great tragedies of American
culture often we are suffering alone
please hear me don't suffer alone
don't do it because that's like that's
where all of the goodness happens I mean
how many times do we experience God
precisely in and through who
others like they say the word they they
are the listening ear
like that's that's where all of the
magic happens
so is the church um following Christ
being disciples it should never be about
pain avoidance but rather processing our
pain to the point of breakthrough in
fact I was thinking this week um
I remember back maybe 15 years ago I was
working in the corporate world and there
was this this kind of debate going
around in the blogosphere and the debate
was do you learn more from success or
failure
and it was sort of like more corporate
setting you know do you learn more from
success or failure
and uh
there's the company called 37 signals
and they wrote a kind of controversial
post but they said it's success
that's the one in and
um and so I thought a lot about that
like do we learn more from success or
failure and I think a little bit is
maybe we need to Define our terms like
on the one hand if you're talking about
like tips and tricks and strategies to
like get ahead
I think you can learn a heck of a lot
from success like you know having a
thing that works and you're like oh my
gosh it worked
keep that in my back pocket you know
what I mean like that thing that works
that like that's incredibly valuable
right but if we are talking
about not tips and tricks and strategies
and like and the thing you know I mean
like but we're talking about our souls
like who we become as people
oh
I think hands down it is failure
and struggle and suffering it's like in
that moment we just come to the end of
ourselves
finally we're undone and what can we do
but trust God
what can we do but trust Christ
but oh what a beautiful thing when we do
it together
when we become midwives for one another
cheering you on
encouraging you stick with it
yeah breakthroughs coming
Maybe not today maybe not tomorrow right
it's not as simple as oh you're
depressed don't worry just say prayer
and tomorrow morning but at some point
you'll experience a joy in the midst of
the suffering and the pain
so that's God's word
in the name of the Father the Son and
the Holy Spirit
amen
so as we come to the table of the Lord
tonight
as we take in the body of Christ and the
bread
the blood of Christ in the wine
we we do so as a as a community
participating in the suffering of Christ
like do you find yourself in pain
tonight suffering in some way grieving I
mean think of it what are we literally
doing we're remembering a broken body in
bloodshed
like this isn't a savior who's like hey
get up get all cleaned up turn that
frown upside down and then you'll be
ready to come to church and be a good
church person you know no no we come as
we are
in the midst of our feelings and we meet
Christ so um the way we're going to do
this is we'll start here with the front
row and we'll just kind of work our way
back so as the row in front of you kind
of comes forward and forms the line once
they're through you can just you know
come on forward
um we practice what's called an Open
Table meaning if you're here tonight and
something in you wants to connect with
the Risen Jesus and you don't have all
of your theology worked out or whatever
um but something in you want to connect
with the Risen Christ then you are free
to come forward regardless of you know
denominational affiliation or uh
whatever
um
so the red is wine
the white is grape juice so um if you're
a kiddo
get the white grape juice my kids
definitely have grabbed the wine before
um and then finally you can just partake
any time you want so no one will come up
and say okay now that bread you know
you'll just you can take it immediately
you could return to your seat have a
kind of quiet moment of reflection and
partake sometimes people kneel here
um well maybe not there today over here
and um you know you can kind of just
partake however you'd like so this is
the table
not at the church
but of the Lord
it's made ready for those who love him
and for those who want to love him more
so come
you who have much faith in you who have
little
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long
you who have tried to follow
in you who have failed
because it's the Lord Jesus himself who
invites you and it's his will that those
who want to meet him should meet him
here
come to the table
[Music]
laughs
foreign
[Music]
I just want to give you permission if
you would like to just stay seated
during this last song and soak it in
it's one for me that was very
encouraging the first time I heard it we
were actually in the middle of our um
process of like working things through
for the table and figuring out like were
we going to need to Branch off and
create this new community
um and there was a lot of pain and a lot
of loss in that process
and it was it was something that gave me
space and permission to have hope for
something in the future while grieving
something in the present and I know as a
Believer
um
when I was
going through probably my
largest period of grief outside of that
time one of the hardest things for me
was to show up at a service where it
kind of felt like you were supposed to
already be on the other side of your
struggle and it kind of felt like there
was this lens of grief that was sort of
missing from my version of Christianity
and um that was one of the things that I
really needed to kind of like
deconstruct and and find a framework
that made space and room for struggle
and grief and
um it's songs like this that I feel like
have have really been an encouragement
in that process so I hope it gives you
room for anything that you might be
going through or even times in the past
that you look back on and feel like you
had to sort of Tuck that away or hide it
from God I hope this gives you
permission
thank you
there is a shadow in the hallway
trying to frighten you don't let the
darkness surround you
you can make
through
don't you give
up on the kingdom
I think it's crashing in no it ain't
worth all the worries
[Music]
they'll still let you in
some days
[Music]
sometimes the weight of decisions
will try to bury you don't let the shame
tell you something
that you know
just cause you feel like a stranger
that don't mean you are
you oh God I could use
what forgiveness is for
eign
[Music]
don't think the best
sometimes
[Music]
day
this song is all day
worries
[Music]
some days
that was beautiful
beautiful and
um in just a moment I'm going to have
Miriam come up and kind of close this
out
but I wanted to introduce two people
that are here tonight that are near and
dear to my heart they're going to hate
me for doing this by the way
so Adam wood is right here Adam is
pastor at the neighborhood church in
Garland
and um the church planter seven years
like doing a good work there in Garland
and um then back here is Charles Kaiser
Charles give a little bit there he goes
um Charles is um pastor at storyline
church and also a church planter it's
there in Richardson is that where y'all
are meeting right yeah Charles is our
church planting coach so he's been
meeting with me for months and um has
been just instrumental with all that's
going on here and um
I just I I know they're gonna hate me
for this but I just didn't want the
night to end without just acknowledging
their presence here it's super super
meaningful and I love how pastors like
when they can encourage one another show
up for one another like that's beautiful
isn't it um like they're busy you know
um so it's yeah I just I love and
appreciate you both so thank you and
thank you for the the work that you're
doing okay I'll give them a quick hand
like thank you
awesome all right so
I uh I I felt one of the lines that
Brett said
um he said spiritual maturity is never
found by going around our suffering but
through it
um I feel like oftentimes I come in here
and Brett is like speaking to my soul
and I don't think it's a coincidence I
think you know God uses him in many ways
to speak to us and I know for myself a
little bit of a vulnerable moment
for much of my life I grew up believing
that I could not feel my feelings
especially the negative feelings and I
could not talk to people about my
feelings
and up until recently I started seeing a
therapist
a big fan of therapy
and I've realized that it's okay to be
angry sometimes and it's okay to be sad
it's okay to feel whatever you feel
and it's encouraged to go to your
community or trusted people and talk to
them about it because you're not made to
go through that alone
so if you're going through something I
highly encourage you to find someone
you're close to to talk to about it so
that you don't face it alone
I want to thank you all so much for
joining us tonight if there are any new
people here we always love that you're
here and checking us out so if you
wouldn't mind going to the table in the
hallway filling out a little white card
with your name just so we can check up
on you see how you're doing
obviously we'd hope to see you back here
again
um if you're in need of a prayer or a
hug or anything feel free to come find
me after service I'm happy to give that
to you say a little prayer for you I
know Brett is happy to do that as well
so here at the table we are committed to
creating an inclusive crisis centered
community that touches lives and
generosity is a key component to that
mission so if you're willing to join us
we want to invite you to go to the
tabletx.org or fill out one of those
forms on the table to support our work
financially
lastly going to send you out with a
benediction
and then we hope to see you all at hat
Creek so before I let you go
um just want to say that you are a child
of God
you are a child of God
and that is true on your best day and
it's especially true on your worst day
so as you go into your week ahead with
this yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between
go filled with the assurance that you
are loved you are worthy and you are
accepted Just As You Are
and go filled with God's holy spirit and
desire to extend those gifts of Grace
and unconditional love to everyone that
you come in contact with
this week for feel free to join us at
hat Creek after the service thanks so
much
[Music]
someday soon these worries
soon
enough